so ii talk alright so probably so one of
the examples i mentioned was this
genetic sample but it letting you find
out a lot of the large-scale data
analysis driven by advertising and
internet environments so we have to slip
a product placement in here so um so you
know the foundations depends on you know
applied math and statistics and computer
science and machine learning and so on
and there's different professional
societies that do this sort of thing and
so one of them science society of
industrial and applied mathematics and
so so has a new journal on sine mods SI
m ODS on mathematics of data science so
I'm an editor on this and it's probably
at least a couple other editors but the
lead editor Tammy cold is here also so
if you have any questions about this you
know grab me at the break or grab Tammy
with questions or send your papers this
way so it's still evolving and what
counts as mathematics of data and how
does it fit into this sort of complex
landscape you know we're talking about
but keep this in mind for sort of good
quality mathematics of data papers that
you might be thinking about
sigh mods si mo mo D s so it's not more
than a year or two but that's because
it's less than a year or two off so
there's I don't know you say six months
or years the goal and it's evolving to
be suited to see it so I don't know is
it's nine months six months was the sort
of the current goal
thirty days right that's after the six
months not doing anything and then Tammy
pings them three times so this is going
to change that so so this is it for the
referees here you have to do something
okay
so um so so so six months nine months is
the Gulf and end what's you know how do
you implement that in so that's trickier
because different areas do things so
that's that's an important consideration
so once you submit your paper and it's
not gotten back and I've start screaming
and if you scream at me or cami or
someone you know we'll keep the ball
moving to the extent possible yeah but
that's a fair concern you know I mean I
think there's a good I mean it's
evolving and we're trying to figure out
how way over the landscape what goes
where it's oh yeah Timmy just looks nice
she's wanting to scream or something
right you know you're saying you're
willing to scream at everyone that the
editors and so on so you'll kick the
kick up yeah all right all right it's
all not happy no Happy's run affair all
right so so I tried to cover sort of the
basic ideas and so the way this so the
sort of theory works in general and then
how you might instantiate it say you
want to do an implementation in LA pack
the details of how blended pick does
stuff is different than the details of
how ALS RN might do something in
distributed environment and that's
different than the details of how you
might do it and you put it in spark or
MPI or on GPUs and so the core ideas are
the same but they diplomat so dove
instantiate in different ways for
implementations if you should in an
application that was a question this
morning about you know images verse
natural language and pre-processing in
different ways and so you know clearly
there may be a condition on British
something might be you know something
easily normalizable in one case and not
in the other and so different in
different areas and use cases things are
going to be very different but also even
if you just want to set a condition on
theory you know things are somewhat
different and so how would you use the
basic ideas so we've seen one example
with high precision numerical
implementations you know get a sketch
use it to construct a pre-conditioner
but since a sketch you know since a
pre-conditioner is used you know to find
a trade-off point you know maybe you
don't need a full subspace embedding
maybe you could lose a dimension or two
and down simple much more aggressively
and so that's an example of how you
might use it in a numerical
implementation and the low-rank
approximation stuff that I mentioned
just briefly at the end you know similar
issues arise matrix completion and
systems of linear equations so these are
two examples of problems that arise some
most use cases here sample rows and
columns either in the canonical basis or
in a randomly rotated basis and this is
more structure when you have the full
subspace information as sort of as a
general rule of thumb if you want sample
elements you typically need other sorts
of structure and so what happens in
matrix completion which is an
idealization for users and preferences
is you say I want to make typically
pretty strong assumptions that you're
low rank and so on which may be useful
as a statistical model but certainly
isn't sort of plausible in practice
there's not K types of people in the
world even if is a statistical modeling
point it they may you may want to model
that and so you make pretty strong
assumptions and then use and the
instructions are you know something
called incoherence and so the hello
world version of incoherence is just
that the leverage scores are flat and it
might be a coordinate aligned version of
that or those other extensions of that
but some sort of incoherent assumptions
and then you use heavier-duty convex
optimization methods and there's been a
lot of work on that laplacian based
linear equations you heard about I think
was earlier today and probably later in
the week so I have a graph it's and it's
an adjacency matrix or it's a laplacian
which is a related matrix and sampling
nodes in the graph for sampling edges in
the graph what does that mean and so
sampling edges and in a
laplacian is an element of that graph
and that essentially corresponds on to
the hood to sampling a row from an edge
incidence matrix and if you want to do
graphs fortification sort of the right
way to do that is to sample based on the
leverage scores of the edge incidence
matrix now you shouldn't call a black
box QR solver because the if it's a
million node graph with 10 million edges
the edge incidence matrix is a million
by 10 million matrix with two non zeros
per row and so you don't to be dense if
I'm using a lot of reasons why you don't
want to do that and so what you need to
do is come up with some notion of
leverage or sense sensitivity or
influence that one is algorithmically
tractable and tool will do something you
want and so what is done there you're
they related to random spanning trees
and low stretch spanning trees and the
idea of low stretch spanning trees is
you might overestimate the influence of
the leverage of any one edge and so
those probabilities will be off right
you're gonna miss estimate some of them
but the sum of the over estimates is not
too bad and so depending on the method
you use and so on the sum of the not the
leverages but the estimates of them is
in the letter we had before not D but D
squared or something so it's low
dimension it's not high well it's not DS
squared because in the graft case here
but it's your d log square d or
something and so it's you can use that
as a proxy so there you're not making
stronger assumptions but you're using
combinatorial techniques so very
different techniques but to get an
estimate of that so there's a lot of
work and machine learning people which
didn't so called kernel based methods
and I have one site at the very end they
put up but there's a lot of work there
Ken mentioned a little I guess he
glossed over at the end on kernel based
methods that was then this is now the
people on neural networks but you know
operationally there's a pretty
substantial theory practice disconnect
and and if you sort of analyze what
different layers are doing you know
different layers are doing some sort of
matrix products and they filter in
different ways and so machine learners
sort of use these techniques at one step
of a 50 layer thing and so what's going
on so I'm not going to talk about those
I want to spend a little bit of time
just talking about sort of some
statistical questions and some
optimization questions and this will be
a little bit
detai a little bit less detail and a
little bit more but the idea is to sort
of touch on the same sort of themes I
was talking about before that there's
certain structure results the questions
you want to ask you know you'll get very
different answers and sort of
highlighting some connections there may
help to clarify some things
so I'll price but most of the time on
statistics a little bit optimization you
heard a little bit about that this
morning and your host first-order
methods and you hear about second-order
methods tomorrow and I'll just point out
how these things fit together and a lot
of sort of open questions here if you
take us to so those the foundations of
data theoretical foundations a big did I
think was those run here at sevens five
years ago and so I was preparing this I
took a step back and said so what's
similar and what's different to them so
that was then and so this is now there's
a lot of questions that are open here
and there's a bunch of hello worlds but
I'll try and sort of highlight some
things and hopefully that gives you a
flavor what might be going on in the
whole space so there's more information
on these slides or at 39 of a thousand
two or whatever so I'm not going to go
through everything in detail but but
these are available and follow up with
questions and so on so statistical
approaches so you know I don't know what
so what statistics and machine learning
and if I had a controversial thing to
say I'd say it but you know one of these
things so let's just say people
self-identify in different ways and said
let's say that's sort of what you do so
for us what's the so that this
difference is oftentimes their cultural
are not technical but those cultural
differences you know are substantial in
terms of the way you ask questions what
you think is interesting I do just want
to get a better precision recall curve
or maybe you're designing an experiment
when you want to understand something
the differences changed with time now
versus five years ago versus five years
now and the two groups interact with I
think theoretical computer science and
randomized linear algebra these sort of
foundational questions and rather
different ways and so so
with that I'll move on I mean we can
talk at the happy hour on Thursday more
about that if you want so a statistical
perspective on call it algorithmic
leveraging so statistics samples data
from the world and so there's a lot of
stuff on this and there's been a lot of
work on with sampling methods and if
you're familiar with this in particular
things like bootstrap from the jackknife
and here the idea is that you have the
computer now you can compute lots of
stuff you don't need to write down
everything analytically and so you can
compute estimates and the idea is that
if I have this sitting in front of me
the data here maybe I can resemble this
in a way that makes a statement about
the world and so you're a sample and so
if I have n data points here I might
resemble end things with replacement but
if I do that a thousand times each of
the things I sample is a different
instantiation of the world and if I can
understand something about the
variability on my thousand samples I
might be able to do some sort of
inference and so so particular if I have
n things here and I'm sampling and
roughly you know I'm doing a very
different thing than we've been talking
about so far right you know you're not
sampling low dimension or rank parameter
you're sampling high dimensional but of
course you're asking a very different
question and so what's the connection
and there's one of those things that you
know takes a while to figure out and the
differences are more cultural than
technical but sort of the sort of
exaggerated just a little bit on the
hardest part here sort of is are you
minimizing like a X minus B or sort of X
beta minus y so I mean I can't tell you
how many times I've had a conversation
and people talk about X and a terms that
you talk about two different axes and
then it's clear after now why and if
you're talking with someone from Greece
you know and you know the is that a B or
a beta and that becomes a base so you
know little things like this where
certain things are sort of obvious after
a lot of effort so X beta equilibrium
going with different letters now for the
next few slides to make things a little
uncomfortable if you've never seen this
before or comfortable if you've never
been familiar with the other notation so
you know active beta so you have a
vector the idea is you have a matrix
this could be random or fixed you know
there's different land design a fixed
design and there's some ground truth
beta naught and I have some noise
process and
generate wise and so the question is I
want to you know I want to find baton
odd I want to find an approximate to
approximation to that and so the answer
is this right this is your a transpose a
inverse sort of thing that we had before
Y is y hat is a projection matrix of Y
so what is what is the hat relate that
we were talking about before so this
what is this thing so this is a
complicated way to write and a thought
on a projection out of the column space
of X right so this is H is equal to u u
transpose where u is your Q from your QR
decomposition for example or from an SVD
here from anything so you take your data
and you project it down so that this is
the Hat matrix because it takes your non
hatted thing and it puts a hat on it and
see if you go to statistics books as
hats there and so if you have u u
transpose and you ask yourself what is
the I I element of that that's the III
element of that and that's equal to the
I roll this tall matrix so I get all my
Squared's right so this is exactly we've
been talking about and the reason this
is outlying is because when you project
down the diagonal its large and you can
ask about off diagonal elements and but
in the simplest case so these this is
the leverage of thoughts of the points
randomly sampled some number of
constraints I'm just using different
letters but this is solve the
sub-problem so this is just to show you
the same thing we saw before it's
different letters and the theorem we had
before is that if you do that sketch and
solve this isn't preconditioning is to
just to take the sketch and solve that
your 1 plus epsilon take your
approximate solution plug it in your 1
plus epsilon or the solution vectors are
you know up to a condition number
epsilon close so there's the same thing
you had before this was written with
different letters and you could ask you
know I'm constructing this estimate of
beta right beta naught is what the world
is and I want to get an approximate
version of beta by solving least squares
and that's optimal in certain sentences
or maybe you sketched a version of lead
2 squares which might be slightly
suboptimal
it might be faster for instance and so
let's say Omega is whatever the
sketching process might be you can look
at X transpose X but the sampled version
of that I'd say read through the DS
sometimes people you know the dying of
rescaling is put inside the S sometimes
it's not so it's read through the DS and
and it is for scaling factors that could
be absorbed into the into the test which
is your sampling or projection matrix
and so your estimate is you know X
transpose X but with some sort of
sketching or sampling process in here
times X transpose sampled version of Y
okay this is this is good but you know
how does this depend on the sub sampling
process so it depends on a very
complicated way right now it's sort of a
nonlinear way so something that is 2013
or you know a while ago by now is you
can ask yourself sort of a Taylor
expansion and you can expand this around
the different places but in particular
around the OLS solution and get
something of this form so you don't need
to parse all this but just realize it's
something of this form minus a residual
that in that case we didn't analyze you
could try and analyze it so the domain
of of convergence Overkill's probably
where you have a subspace embedding you
could probably get it with something Els
but I don't know the answer so I believe
that sort of as open if you do expansion
like this since this is going to tap
back into some of the other things I
inserted these actually in the wake of
this morning there was a question about
half leverage or the generalization of
leverage and half uniform why would you
do that is that implicit regulation is
that what's going on so what we have
here is an expansion and so you can say
how good is this in comparison to
whatever I might care about so here's an
answer
so given this expansion you can say what
is the expectation and the expectation
could be conditional on your Y vector or
could be unconditional and you have two
different and the expectation in the two
cases you know the expected value is the
OLS solution or the ground truth plus
you know something
and there's a variance and so the
variance is something of this form your
X transpose X inverse X transpose
inverse plus something and so you have a
piece of bread and a piece of bread and
your salami is something in there right
and so zero down here so depending on
whether your conditional or not you know
you get one over pi and so pi here is
the probability it's a sampling
probabilities you get this in the
denominator and you get this for a
different reason than you had before
right you had what we had before was
you're pulling something out I'm
constructing an estimator here I'm
basically doing an expansion and saying
you know what is the variance of the
estimator that I've constructed so
that's appearing in the denominator as I
mentioned this and put this in here
because if you're asking a CS question
you want to get your subspace embedding
you have that basically you're done the
rest sort of goes through and it's not
just the case that you don't quite need
that for for other other sorts of
questions right you know the iterative
least squares you also need to worry
about other things and so this is the
simplest version of that you need to
worry about very small probabilities so
to get the subspace embedding you need
to find the large ones deal with the
small ones however you can underestimate
them I mean it doesn't matter
but since these estimators have this in
the denominator if you're asking a
statistical question about the world not
the algorithmic question about the
machine you're going to get those
probabilities in the denominator here
and that could cause a problem yeah how
bad is that problem we'll get to the
saying but you know that could cause a
problem
so you know for any sampling or scaling
process this is leverage or knock this
is Gaussian or not this is let me it
could be any of a range of thing you're
going to get conditional unconditional
estimates around the OLS solution of the
ground truth the the variance is going
to depend on the details of the sampling
process and so this is this is going to
hold when the higher order terms are
small they could be larger which case
you have worse problems if you're simply
gonna formally the variance is gonna
scale us n over R so this is different
but but similar to what we saw before
that if you sample uniformly and ask a
worst-case question you're gonna have
bad scaling let's say B lab is this used
vanilla leverage it's going to be low
dimension / RP / R so if you make are a
little bit larger than P you sample a
little bit more than the small dimension
things will be good if you approximate
the leverage this is empirical value
fact if you approximate the leverage
score sort of an in any which way you
like call that a lab you get the same
things to the first order there's very
small differences and let's call s Lev
essentially what you saw this morning
you know a half leverage meaning a half
bias yourself towards the non-uniformity
plus a half uniform now how do you
implement that we had to go to a lot of
effort to find these leverage scores how
do you implement half leverage plus half
the uniform of course that's easy ideas
flip a coin what some properties sample
uniform and some public sample in this
complicated so the very simply a simple
thing to implement but you know you're
going to moderate these small terms in
the denominator because you can't have
levered you can't have those terms be
too small because now I'm sampling with
respect to probably that can't be too
too small because I'm it's half a
uniform and what you'll see is the bias
this is a variance as a function of
alpha going between 0 and 1 you know you
can get a sweet spot and so you saw a
half this morning in this particular
setup it's 0.7 so the prediction if you
ask never mind
optimization iterations the simplest
possible question is that how this
performing least square is asked vanilla
least squares look at expansion around
so the solution and you know what if I
sample expect to leverage and and you do
worse but if you had mix in a little bit
of something that's very easy to mix in
you'll do better and so this is in the
straightforward least squares case you
can see that similar things like this in
low ranked aprox
Meishan and you heard this morning about
so the version of this and then a
first-order stochastic optimization
problem so this is a relatively simple
fix but it's an example of a structure
that that's a little bit more fine scale
that you might want to capture that
something else this alpha is I might
have alpha 1 minus alpha backwards but
it's it's it's leverage plus alpha you
know 1 - leverage 1 minus alpha leverage
plus alpha uniform so it makes a little
bit of uniform you could have mix all
this stuff in this particular setup it
didn't matter you could use their own
arms whatever but you know it mix in a
little bit of something else actually
and and that buys a lot yeah and so this
is a regular I mean it's it's not a
regulation on the final solution it's an
implicit regularization at an
intermediate step so some of this
morning asked about that so you know
essentially that's what's what you're
doing you're hedging against very small
things and and you're correcting that a
little bit and this decreases the
variance of the estimator this decreases
the variance of the estimator in that
expansion yeah and so yeah so it's it's
not it necessary bias I mean maybe you
could relate it to a bias on the
solution vector we didn't know and
should look at that but it decreases the
variance in the solution vector yeah so
that's one thing yes from a few years of
action I wanted to slip this in because
an open problem there that you know I
need one of these thorns in your side is
we did this Taylor expansion but you
know we never it was a little bit hand
waving you never quantified that so how
do you how do you how do you might want
to quantify that and this gets to the
question is the objectives we're looking
at earlier the things we want or should
there be some other objective and we
know the answer right yeah it depends we
need a microphone oh it depends so it so
what's the objective you should look at
so if we're interested in understanding
the effect of the sampling process this
Taylor expansion was a nice hello world
to illustrate in a very simple context
around a range of trade-offs but I had
it
this depends on the subsampling in a
very sort of complicated way very
non-uniform land so something that's not
sort of common in statistics when you
have more complicated some sampling
estimators like that is to say not how
does a subsample perform on fixed end
but take an asymptotic limit and gain
some insight there so here we have beta
hat I've made things bold but is the
estimator we had before and there's two
parts of the randomness one is and why
and that's randomness in the data one is
in W that's randomness in the algorithm
and so how do they interact I mean a
particular randomness in the algorithm
is that's entering in this sort of
nonlinear way and so take a page from
asymptotic statistics and say ask how
would this can we get some sort of
asymptotic distribution as n goes to
infinity so now there's a couple
subtleties it's easy to take a limit
that makes everything trivial so talk to
me offline if you want to avoid that but
if you're not careful you can take you
know if you fix N and let P go to
infinity or vice versa it's easy to
modernize things too much you've got to
be a little bit careful I'm going to
gloss over that here we're going to look
at it at a maximum likely well I mean an
example of asymptotic analysis is a
maximum likelihood estimator so there's
no explicit form here and so you may
take an asymptotic limit and ask about
the asymptotic MSE for example so the
mean squared error this is just a way to
write mean squared error which is bias
plus variance in terms so you have the t
be an estimator and and for a parameter
vector nu this is the way to write down
an MSc you've seen it you haven't but
don't parse all the letters if you
haven't it that is it you could ask the
asymptotic version of that so put an A
here and you know do an asymptotic
version of that and so I'm not going to
go through the all the details here but
you can get an asymptotic mean square
error and an asymptotic sort of variance
covariance matrix and expectation if you
do that in the setting of a sin the
question what's the effect of the
sampling on this prediction you can show
the following so under sort of
assumptions that I think are reasonable
but there could be interesting questions
about coming up with a more reasonable
set of assumptions in the sense that
it's it's as I said it's actually hard
to get a nice set of assumptions that
don't render thing
trivial so I think this is sort of
interesting follow-ups here but under
sort of a reasonable set of assumptions
then as n goes to infinity we're gonna
get something of this form so if you've
seen asymptotic statistics you may
recognize that if you haven't don't
worry we're gonna get something slightly
different that we had before and I think
it's on the next yeah and so this this
is the usual sort of asymptotic
normality claim you're gonna be
asymptotically normal so in particular
in unconditional inference and you know
if the if the predictors are diverging
and your conditional you there's more
complicated version of this beta tittle
is asymptotically unbiased estimator of
beta naught and the asymptotic variance
covariance matrix is given in this form
so I've glossed over some of the details
of what the particular equations
technique meant it mean because I want
to say here's something we can go into
more detail later if you're said here's
something how would this manifest itself
in anything we've been talking about so
what do we care about do we care about
the the solution vector in this look you
know notation beta before X in the
actual solution vector do we care about
the objective which is something related
to x times beta maybe minus residual do
we want to feed this into a correlation
matrix estimation or something which
case might be x transpose x times beta
and so depending on which of those and
and from everything we've been talking
about before they're the same get your
get your embedding and and it'll go
through if you're asking this sort of
question if you want to estimate beta
these in fact are the optimal
probability is not for the MSE but for
the asymptotic MSE if you want to
estimate X beta which is why these will
be the optimal probabilities so here is
X transpose X inverse this is X X
transpose X inverse times you know X I
which is the square root of the leverage
scores this is something that's a little
bit more complicated has this variance
term in the denominator
this correlation term of the denominator
and if you want X transpose X beta you
get something which is not Rho norm
squared but Rho norm so what are these
you want to do know the answer right
it's going to depend so there's two
points here one is that things are
simpler or harder there's a richer array
of things you can capture here depending
on what you're asking for but you're
also more robust to missing a few things
if you lose one dimension or something
some of the figures I glossed over you
induce a little bit of bias that's
typically not the dominant term in these
empirical results you introduce a little
bit of bias he may decrease the variance
so things manage to get better if you
lose a few dimensions so structure
results so this is this was neat because
we're able to relate to something that I
knew about but didn't know how to relate
to these sort of sampling processes
these asymptotic methods and so that was
a nice connection what about these
structure results that we've been
talking about
and those big just I mean similar
results you can see in a low-rank
approximation and kernel methods and
other things but but the simplest sort
of setup is in the least squares case so
recall the original problem beta OLS I
guess I made o LS capital and so doing
sketch and solve again little details
some people assume something this such
that that's immediately satisfied other
people don't so let's define two things
so the efficiency typically has to do
with the ratio of variances if I have an
estimator I have another estimator that
is better variance a means and better
variance properties this one's better
and so I ask about the relative
efficiency and in particular let's say
for a prediction problem where I look at
the difference between the beta vectors
filtered through X maybe in expectation
for the sampled version minus the OLS
version and you can also ask about but a
different estimator you know residual
efficiency so take my solution plug it
back in and look at Y minus X beta from
the sketch or Y minus X beta from the
OLS so these are sort of very
statistical objectives in terms of
efficiency there's an expectation here
how does that expectation relate to what
we've been talking about
so there's no sort of natural
correspondence with sort of an
algorithmic approach I mean to write
things formally you could say well
define Y in terms of X with a linear
model we're essentially you know you
just look at the you know the error is
any vector that lies in the null space
of X that's so the closest
correspondence in which case you'll get
some sort of worst case error metric
like this which is the first cousin of
what we've been talking about where
there's a supreme not an expectation so
these letters are almost the same we had
on the previous slide except this is
supremum here instead of an an
expectation so again you know which of
these do you want and it really depends
on some of the use case let me in the
interest of time say you know if you're
interesting the worst case estimator
you'll get an estimate 1 plus of Suprema
more something like this you might ask
you to parse this that's a spectral norm
that's a subspace embedding you have the
norm here but you can make that unit
link if you wanted plus something on how
that interacts with with the projection
matrix on the sample if you're in a
statistical setting you'll get something
similar but instead of having a spectral
norm here you'll have a Frobenius norm
again blowing down to matrix
multiplication result but it 4b Gnaeus
now rather than a spectral model which
do you want and so that's going to
depend really on the particular use case
you know with the with both notions of
statistical error so we talked before
about how the basic least squares result
for just doing the linear algebraic
projection boiled down to that
structural lemma that had two pieces I
mean here you'll have something similar
I you know let's say alpha is a
parameter that says how close is this to
one or you know away from above zero I
could have another parameter that
corresponds to what's the connection
between the error which could be a
Gaussian random variable anywhere or
could be adversary chosen
perpendicular to the column space and
something else about a 4b Gnaeus norm so
the interesting thing here that was one
of the questions in the last section
that Fred came up and asked me
afterwards is we're relating the
low-rank approximation x' to a bunch of
matrix multiplication results why don't
you just put an identity somewhere and
tear it apart in sort of the obvious way
and you could do that but you're not
going to get the very fine scale
relative our bounds you would you
if you do that you're gonna have a
massive the norm of a matrix and a norm
that depends on a high dimension because
you know the Frobenius norm you know the
sampling so this thing might not be high
dimension but it's high dimension - low
dimension dotting into an orthogonal
matrix and so it's going to be a high
dimensional factor and so this is going
to be related to I and a lot of
statistical objectives you need the
sampling complexity to be much higher I
don't know if I have it here but I want
to mention it if I don't everything so
the sampling complexity being much
higher is actually a problem not just in
two ways one if you want to get high
precision solutions you need to couple
it with an iterative numerical method
also if you want air entered in
essentially statistical objectives and
for to sort of slightly different
reasons but both can be taken care of if
you sort of consider iterative
techniques and so the inner of
techniques will be a little bit
different so if you--if I'm just into
the basic least squares problem you
could say I have ax minus B
the solution you know is the pseudo
inverse of a times B this is X opt and
I'm going to have X tittle opt is on the
sampled version of a pseudo invert
attend the sampled version of B and you
saw the results you got before like hey
the 1 over up some squares in the
denominator you know etc etc you could
say you know B may have error right
because B is X beta minus y and we know
that y is equal to X beta plus noise and
so you know fix this
you know hypothesize that you just put a
bunch of error there and so why has gobs
of Merit right now you're down sampling
on it and so is that going to cause
problems the answers are could it's not
going to have problems if you interested
in the objective on the data in front of
you but if your interests in the world
that you know you may have problems so
why don't you do the following and make
sure I get my letters right so I'm going
to mix letters why don't I do it to be
consistent with what I have there to say
X transpose X beta minus or equals X
transpose Y because the normal equations
right
don't sample there you're going to do a
matrix vector product they're just deals
that separately but that's not gonna be
a pain point for the iterative algorithm
and put you know sampled version of X
transpose sampled version of X data is
equal to X transpose Y and then calling
it algorithm so you could do that and so
I actually taught a class a few years
ago and Merkel and she followed up and
said learn to do such and such and knew
so this is I think it's called Hessian
sketch and so you can use this now
that's you know of interest potentially
for the least squares problem in a
certain corner case but it's nice
because you can apply to a range of
other convex optimization questions and
you can you ask about first order of
methods or second order method then
probably some of the second-order
methods you hear about tomorrow we'll
use variants of this sort of technique
simply approximating the Hessian and how
well do you approximate the Hessian
so yeah so there it's it's not I don't
know what you call this this isn't
sketch and solved but this is sketch
part of and solve and then iterate and
sketch part
so I love to think of an acronym for
that but you could do that
and that actually grew out of this
particular me and so in particular the
fact that you need the sampling is going
to depend on the high dimension you can
get around by iterating in that way I'm
not going to go into detail about that
but you can get around that in that way
again bunch of empirical conclusion I'm
going to gloss over a little bit of the
theory the Pyrrhic results actually very
consistent with the theory getting good
statistical results if you're asking
statistical machine learning questions
can be easier harder I mean it's it's
incomparable in some ways it's easy you
can cut corners and otherwise it's
harder because you're asking sort of
different and harder questions and I
think the trade-offs are just very
different to then you could see if
you're asking Numerical questions or
sort of worst-case algorithmic questions
so a lot of sort of open questions there
you see it here in least squares I like
least squares because it's simple you
saw this this morning you saw this this
morning and then in a stochastic first
order optimization algorithm you can
solve the first problem you can iterate
you can quantify it in terms of
condition number trade-offs so a lot of
these themes you'd see in more
complicated versions something also cute
say you're solving a Ridge regression
problem there's sampling there's noise
in the data there's noise in the
algorithm how do they relate so
I'm in risk of classical sketch men risk
of optimal solution so here's a
regularization parameters the x-axis
y-axis is risk and down as good similar
for the the Hessian sketch the point is
that the values of the regularization
parameter are very different right and
so this is Ridge regression right this
is I don't know who did where you know
this is when was this done this isn't
Gauss and Hotelling but this must be
1950 or something right so the simplest
possible thing you can imagine analyze
it ask how would you choose that you
know how did you choose that regulation
parameter and not surprisingly it just
haven't been pointed out before if you
have noise in the data and you have
noise in the algorithm they're going to
interact in certain ways and you can
over regularize you can under regularize
and so this is Ridge regression what if
I tack on a non-linearity in a
convolutional layer and wrap this up
with 50 things you know talking to each
other the way stochastic optimization
first-order methods and second-order
methods work is you're the swing you
over parameterize you drive the error to
zero and then you have 50 knobs you
fiddle with to get things right one of
the knobs will do this to the other knob
will do this the other no so they're all
the knobs will do something like this in
very complicated ways and so this is a
nice example to see this in a very
simple setting how noise and the data
interact with noise in the algorithm
right so noise in the algorithm
what's your batch size what's your
learning rate you know are you doing
stochastic first-order or you're
approximating the Hessian and
second-order and so there's a lot of
knobs here that feed into that and even
in the simple setting we can see this
never mind something more complicated
setting so it's really hard to think
about those neural network applications
in terms of something like this because
there's so many moving parts and the
convex theory really sort of
disconnected from in a lot of cases sort
of how that actually appear in practice
and so there's a nice sort of playground
to understand how the implicit
regulation behaves with noise and the
data connection of bootstrapping
let me gloss over there's a time and
just say so I mentioned bootstrapping is
a technique to estimate parameters if
you were sample data but you're asking
an inferential question I want to know
how well I can make an inferential claim
how so how does that relate to our
talking about you know there's a world
and then you get a copy of the day and
you put it on your machine which might
be a hung 50 machines if you have your
distributed data center or something and
then you put it on your sample which is
your RAM or whatever and then you chew
on it right you're making an objective
here you know the 1 plus epsilon bounds
we saw before make a statement about the
sample talks to the machine
bootstrapping makes some claim about how
the particular sample you have today
might relate to the sample you get
tomorrow you know from from the
distribution from the world can you
couple the two together so sort of a
hello world result that does it not in
the way of changing those together but
saying you know if I want to get beyond
sort of a worst case error I found could
I use the sample that I construct do
bootstrapping on that to get a better
estimate of the number of samples I need
to and the idea is that if I have a
sample I can look at the variability in
that sample to get an estimate of what
the variability would look like in the
full data set so I'm glossing over the
details in the last few slides but the
short answer is yes so this will be sort
of a way to parameterize algorithms in
terms of properties of the data
numerical analysts have asked questions
about coming up with a post area or I
sort of condition number estimators or
estimates so think of this as sort of a
statistical analogue of this this was a
trade off space here these computations
are very highly scalable you can do them
in parallel and so on so there's a bunch
of hello world results nice theory in
terms of estimating extreme extreme
value of processes that was not blackbox
at least in terms of any sort of
anything we knew and so the numerical
sort of performance is encouraging so
that sort of a whirlwind of a few
statistical methods and just to say now
you know relative to some number view
ago I think things are sort of maturing
and even in a sort of relatively simple
context you can ask questions that are
analogous to and much more complicated
coming back to not convex optimization
problems and understand these two other
trade-offs for sort of foundations of
algorithms let me mention two other
things just sort of how some first-order
and second-order ideas in terms of
optimization might relate to we've been
talking about but maybe I'll pause for a
second see if anyone had any questions
on I guess this number six this bullet
is if there's any questions
oh this one does well complete strapping
reading names yeah I don't know what the
hit you mean how it's done or what's the
what's the name mean I don't know the
name the historical so I want to make an
inference I want to make a prediction
about the world I have some data here I
could come back tomorrow and draw the
same data of course in a lot of cases I
can't because a lot of people had to die
to in cancer trials or something so you
might not be all that but yeah you could
come back tomorrow and so do this a
thousand times but then three years is
up and so so you might not want to say
come back tomorrow many many times you
might just don't say I have one copy of
the data you know what can you do and so
what you could do here if the I mean so
this is gonna over simplify but if the
data set size and construct a sample of
size n or comparable to n from this data
but sample uniformly and with
replacement so if your sample uniformly
in with replacement you don't get
everything a coupon collecting says
you're gonna need n login to touch
everything so you get what's the number
is it sixty three percent or something
so you get sixty three percent of the
samples and of course you've sampled
some things multiple times and so now
you have a data set so this is D but
when you've done that now I have D one
of course I could have D 2 D 3 I can do
this a thousand times
and I could do this in parallel on a
thousand machine so if computation is
relatively cheap I could look at these
things and I could construct estimators
from this I'm going to get something you
know behaves like this as a function of
number of samples or of whatever and you
know look at the 99th percentile of this
distribution and then under assumptions
and in the right limits that will
correspond to something here and so I
can make inference about what I'll see
tomorrow based on our sampling here
yeah
all right so here's optimization and a
slide so I'll do less justice to it than
you heard this morning but so
optimization is a funny space right and
I feel like it's a little bit more
complicated even than just vanilla least
squares right and and there's a lot
going on in a straightforward low-rank
approximation problem ization seems that
if there's more moving parts in terms of
you know what's the objective you care
about do you care about this objective
do on high precision you do a number of
iterations as an expense per iteration
which of those things is expensive or
cheap and then a lot of machine learning
applications you say well really they
don't want this objective you want this
other one but then you say well in fact
we've over parameterize it so we do want
that objective but we have a lot of
knobs and so we're gonna and so it's
it's a little bit so there's a lot of
moving parts so so think how might this
relate to we've been talking about so
you could take a step back can I ask the
more general question but how might this
relate to we've been talking about so
roughly you know you're at a point and
you know there's this first so so what's
the distinction between first-order
methods and second-order method so
sometimes people say the distinction is
one looks at the gradient and one looks
the Hessian is that is that you know if
that's the case where does l-bfgs sit I
mean so the simple story is first-order
methods a look at gradient information
and second-order methods a look at has
the information but the full stir is a
lot more textured than that and I think
people people have a tendency to like
first-order methods for a range of
technical and not technical reasons but
one of the reasons is they're just sort
of simple right you have a million
dimensional function and you can draw
something with one or two dimensions
here and everyone sort of knows what it
means to roll downhill that seems a
little bit more subtle right the second
order information says well there's a
trade-off between how far I step and you
know where I turn all right maybe I
could take a small step here or a much
larger step in this direction and so the
the curvature on that surface is is a
sort of a dis much more subtle thing and
I think that you know that's a vector
that's just a bunch of numbers that you
put in a row or a column right this is a
matrix it's just sort of a much more
complicated object so I think thinking
about this stuff's harder
and so I think people don't do it now
people have done a lot in scientific
computing so a lot of people said well
we're going to work with first-order
methods and one way to think about
first-order methods is the sort of
Oracle access to a gradient in which
case that's that's the hard distinction
between the two oh it's not clear that's
so the most natural distinction as a
practical matter if you would implement
things so those comments aside and we
can talk later more detail about that I
think of first-order methods as
computing a gradient or some
approximation to it and then moving a
step in that direction and think of
second-order methods is doing the same
thing except they say because this is
the same right this is just the gradient
but they say well rather than just
moving a step in that direction they say
you know is there a natural way to step
and they say a natural way to step is
related to this inverse of the Hessian
but of course you should never think of
computing that inverse of the Hessian
right because you never would right
you might approximate the solution you
might do an iterative algorithms lots of
things you might do but you never
actually compute that and so you'd say
well rather than taking a step here I'm
going to rotate and stretch and rotate
and that's the right direction to move
in and so there's gonna be a trade-off
here how expensive is it to implement
something that approximates this versus
just move in this direction and I think
what happens a lot machine learning is
you try and approximate this given just
gradient access or given very noisy
gradient access or given noisy and
gradient access with a few other knobs
and so what's the what sort of going on
here so with first-order methods so from
the perspective of it later I'll be
around
of course the whole term if people are
said from the perspective what we're
talking about here we wanted to ask the
question you know both of these things
sample in some way and solve some
problem and what make the connection
between them be so SGD is sort of a
vanilla first order method you get a
noisy version of a gradient it's widely
used in practice because of its
scalability and so on
it works on convex problems but it's
also just a procedure you just run it
when the theories for the convex case
that 99% use case and if people apply it
to other objectives but you know so you
can apply it to anything you
theoretical statements that are very
different we've been talking about here
yesterday in particular this morning
you're hearing a little bit about most
of theoretical computer science and
randomized linear algebra grew up out of
that make statements of the form if I
run so many steps stop
I'm epsilon good all right that's very
different than saying I don't know how
long it takes to get here but once I get
here I'm going to converge at some rate
which is this form of the statement that
you're getting a lot of optimization
algorithms you know a convergence rate
and in the tour it is sort of
incomparable and it may be for me it in
terms of differential assumptions and so
on
so for randomized Linea Alba you get
better worst case guarantees but you
know for a more narrow class of problems
and so it's typically formulated in in
either a numerical style or a theory
volume style and so the question is
could you combine the two and this is
one of those things that it holds more
generally we actually asked the question
in the context of least absolute
deviations regression because if you ask
it for just a pure linear algebra
problem you can't beat core linear
algebra methods and if you ask it for a
fully general convex problem you know
just vanilla matrix methods have nothing
to say so think about in terms of least
absolute deviation regression which is
sort of a nice sweet spot between the
two or at least yeah she said
convergence rate she did so she said I'm
gonna converge at this race I go from
one iteration to the next I get however
much better but she doesn't say how good
am I on the first step
so take some length of time to get near
an optimum but once you near it you know
you'll convert at some rate
relative to where she started
are you gonna go more into local and
global convergence issues tomorrow yeah
so in people in theory of algorithms use
these sort of techniques sometimes but
it's typically for more combinatorial
problems we can bound things related to
the width of the initial set and so you
can say for worst-case inputs I converge
at some rate which is different than
saying you know I'm going to converge
when I'm near the solution or something
so yeah so I think if this is least
squares but you put a 1 here or a p-norm
there and it's it's a more general class
of problems and this is one of these
things that took a while to figure out
and then once we figured it out someone
said yeah obviously but I had talked to
them 6 months before and they didn't
tell me that the time so so where's the
randomness here is it in the noise or is
it in the algorithm so least squares and
least absolute deviations these are
deterministic problems there's no
randomness you can take in this holes
more generally but you can take a
deterministic problem hey is your matrix
u is think of it as a nice basis for the
span of a were nice in the l2 senses an
orthogonal matrix and it's a
generalization of that in l1 in other
cases and you can relate it to a
stochastic optimization problem which is
the expectation of a random variable
drawn from this sum from drawn from some
distribution of H where H is an
estimator
all right so this connections more
general that we're talking about here
but in particular related deterministic
optimization problem to a stochastic
optimization problem and then ask how do
you solve a stochastic optimization
problem and to summarize a semester
worth of stochastic optimization I mean
there's a couple approaches somewhat
confusing set of names Si and si a so
stochastic optimization which
essentially says start with some initial
point iteratively solved the objective
and that each that each step of the
iteration get a new sample point if you
do mini-batches you get ten new sample
points drawn from some distribution and
the current weight is updated you move
in the gradient direction or some sub
size and so on you can do si a sample
average approximation which is going
pull some stuff out you know solve so
sketching sketching solve sample
endpoints from a distribution and solve
this following call it empirical risk
minimization we wouldn't call it that in
the islands would call it that in
machine learning but solving empirical
risk
pull a sample out solve the sub problem
and so which of these is better or worse
they're they're incomparable they're
going to be different right don't you
get some differences so to solve the
stochastic optimization problem how do
you sample essay or essay a which
properly distribution these sample is a
uniform or not which basis did you use I
said it's a nice basis how nice is nice
neon you're doing preconditioning or not
which solver to use so a lot of these
things if we said sketched and solved
how do we solve the sub problem maybe we
solved with an SGD algorithm and I
didn't tell you that I mean you had a
low precision solution maybe I solved it
to high precision so you can do this and
depending on the decisions you make sort
of vanilla SGD you know as online naive
batch fast if you do batch with some
fancy way you're gonna get randomized
linear algebra there's a trade-off point
in between so this is a hello world and
so you know the paper needs to get
published or better on some certain
corner cases I'm glad to talk offline
about that I think the interesting thing
is it set up a way to say there's a few
steps how you did generating data is
this
at that step is this at that step retime
the two together which basis do you use
and which probabilities to use and then
how do you solve you solve something
exactly a partner so there's two ways to
view this one is that I'm gonna use
randomized linear algebra to get a good
initial point so it's burning faizon SGD
where I can't say anything and then I
converge I'm gonna use randomized when
you're out to get good point why do I
know it's a good point because I get a
subspace embedding I'm epsilon good or
Epsilon's 1/2 so I have some sense of
how close I am iterate and drive that to
zero or I could say well I'm just doing
randomized linear algebra and at each
step rather than calling a solve that's
good to machine precision I get a very
low quality solution from an SGD and so
which of those two you prefer depends on
what you prefer but this does both of
those things and they're two sides of
the same coin
so second-order methods so I'll treat
second-order methods even more cursor
than first-order methods partly because
you'll get to a couple hours of that
tomorrow second-order optimisation
so if you're solving convex problems
things are relatively simple you want to
get here you know to the minimum there's
a question about you know if there's
curvature in different directions and so
you know they got it there's a condition
number in the Lipschitz constants and he
says so you got to be a little bit
careful if you're if you're wanting to
apply for a store but a particular
second order methods to not convex
problems you have to ask you know when I
run out of steam in the algorithm stops
what did I find
cuz first order method looking at just
derivative information fine do you think
they actually find you come with very
different guarantees than you would with
second order methods so a notion of
optimality for second order methods as I
want to be second-order optimal I want
the gradient to be zero the gradient to
be zero mean I'm flat which calculus 101
what the grading be to zero and if I
want to be I'm part of this so you know
I want I want to find a minimum so I
want the curvature to be up so I want
all the eigen values I want the
curvature the second derivative to be a
positive say the norm of the gradient is
zero but it's not zero which is very
small and say that the first say that
the HESI and the second derivatives it's
not all that all the eigen values are
positive but you know they're smart
they're more than negative epsilon H
they get more than something very small
and negative more than negative point
one now this could be point one or this
could be ten to the minus ten ditto with
this right and you can imagine that the
sort of questions you'd ask might be
very different in those two cases so
there is a question about and a lot of
people I think spend time saying you
know this most recent version of an
optimization autumn's better because I
have a trade-off point between epsilon G
and epsilon H and you know epsilon G to
the negative three halves and epsilon H
to the negative seventeen forty thirds
or something I think that's the way
these things I use much less useful than
asking about the dimensional dependence
and sort of modularizing the question of
can I get a good solver in a
preconditioning sense from sort of
what's the structural result that's
giving me that because if you understand
that structures like you can use it in a
bunch of other ways just like we saw
with with least squares
so to increase efficiency you want to
use gradient Hessian and in exact
solutions of the underlying sub problems
this is an interesting thing if you're
in computational math it's indirectly
done by a lot of machine learners and
people but not explicitly instead of
highlighting this in a way we've sort of
done analogous we with the linear
algebra might be nice so at least what I
tell people is if someone says I can't
do a second-order method because I have
to invert a Hessian you should sort of
walk out of the room and say you know
why would you think you'd have to invert
a Hessian and the example is every
linear algebra book starts out by saying
we want to solve y equals ax the
solution is X is equal to a inverse Y
all right they do that on page one and a
nice he just crane to say you knew you
guys didn't see this but he just cringed
and then they spend literally they spend
the next four hundred ninety nine pages
saying why you don't do that
and so similarly here so you'd never
invert a Hessian you want to get the
solution tool in your equation how are
you going to do it so look at the
details of the in exact solutions so I'm
not going to go into details that today
I think you'll probably get more about
that tomorrow you can imagine there's
differences between epsilon G's and
epsilon HS let me gloss over that and
say you know a basic structure a result
is if s G slope sample size to estimate
my gradient is something if SH sub
sample size to estimate the Hessian is
something then condition one which
hopefully is right above here maybe it's
on the previous page condition one is a
goodness condition holds
so condition one is going to be mess up
my numbers
it was one
so condition one is condition I want my
gradient have seen information to be
well approximated so if I sample enough
why is that that's because this is an
approximate you know this is an
approximate matrix product
it's the Dell vector dotted into an all
one's vector maybe and there's an
approximate matrix matrix product so how
would you use that in an iterative
algorithm so it's simpler to talk about
it in the non convex case because it's
moving parts and highlight certain
things so this trust region and cubic
regularization method that I won't
describe them in detail there's a lot of
work in machine learning that says I
want to get iteration complexity and I
want bounds of the following form Pasi
and minus approximate either in general
or dotted into the particular direction
of moving is less than something 1/2 or
whatever times the norm of this step
squared all right so if you're familiar
that position this is stronger than the
Dennis Mori condition what is this it's
convenient because you have a squared
there so other things will be company
but stronger in that condition and so
for a groups of things you have examples
we can relax that to a statement with
the matrix matrix product is
approximated in the same way but to
finer scale epsilon times the norm
rather than a norm squared so two things
one this allows you to just take a bunch
of the ideas from randomized linear
algebra and matrix sketching whether you
like leverage or not etc etc
feed it into convex and non convex
optimization well that's a
straightforward convex or thrust region
in cubic organization type not convex so
it's not obvious whether just removing a
squared this is very deep and of proof
does that matter and the answer is yes I
mean one quasi Newton a bunch of other
things people use in practice don't
satisfy this so you're developing theory
that sort of doesn't characterize a
broad class of methods that it does
satisfy this two you're able to just
take a large body of sketching sampling
theory and and apply it back so that's a
five-minute summary of maybe something
you hear about for two hours so that's a
little bit over simpler but that's
that's the idea and so you identify a
structural result gotta get the scale
right and then you can start to port the
sketching ideas
use sampling or should use projections
should use Hadamard does she count
sketch should use any of those or should
you use norm sampling or leverage score
sampling you define it depends right so
what does it depend on it depends on the
condition number it depends on the
aspect ratio it depends on all these
moving parts and so so I think you're
asking that question formulating it that
way you open up the doors for a whole
bunch of things you saw some examples of
this when Rachel was talking about you
know looking at the condition number
there and that's a variant of this so it
really depends if something is uniform
for her and the data entry process in
the image case where everything sort of
similar do it one way if things are very
different in scale in terms of natural
language applications do it basically a
different way so whichever one you
prefer you run with that and these will
be gotten more details and tomorrow's
talk so with that let me wrap up all of
this stuff is at the center of a lot of
these foundations of data questions but
a relatively simpler setting but the
only albums used to model these matrices
but also feeds into a lot of these other
problems and randomness you know can be
used in the data and the algorithm and
in a range of ways that sort of toggle
between the two so with that let me wrap
up then I guess we'll call it a day
unless there's any questions
[Applause]
questions you Mike
like Michael